une fois n'est pas coutume sylvie turpin
s'accorde le droit d'exposer dans sa
propre galerie normal c'est la dernière
exposition daga elle s'intitule tout
simplement avec elle pour finir en
beauté
fabienne gaston-dreyfus laurence pas
points ou encore so qu'ang lee
toutes sont ancrés dans le faire ils ont
en commun cette spécificité du processus
sous par exemple kyoung lee elle repart
avec des fonds colorés
elle fait d'efforts mais elle repeint
dessus elle reprend et elle utilise le
gommage par l'art peinture
et
l'artiste rejette son propre ego
travaille à l'instinct se sert de sa
pratique
en fait c'est la technique qui lui donne
ses sujets et donc j'ai appris la
technique de la fresque aux arts
appliqués et je m'en suis pas remise
dort chez j'ai pas du pain sur un
tableau sylvie turpin pratique l'art de
la fresque une méthode utilisée depuis
l'antiquité qui nécessite une grande
habilité
ce qui était important c'était de
réintégrer mon objet tableau enfin ma
fraise que tableau au mur et ils meurent
imr fait il fallait un glissement entre
le mur est l'objet c'est comme ça que
j'ai ré introduit les fonds
oh non
moi j'ai cette liberté de construire le
tableau dont qui se déforment voilà il y
à des angles qui en sont plus il s'étire
et donc j'appelle ça des pouces puisque
j'ai l'impression que la fresque qui est
l origine du tableau elle pousse voilà
elle pousse au mur ça pousse je les
arrose tous les jours tout à l'heure ce
matin elle a même pas voulu parler toute
rencontre
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait là j'y
retourne je ne tourne pas à temps il ya
un truc que j'avais pas comprendre et
d'info vous êtes vus c'était quand
j'étais fière tout à fait prêt dakar non
même bien bien avec moi tu meurs tu peux
pas te tu peux vivre une soirée trop
pour toi tu occupé de ma vie est très
compliqué je la passe pour personne dire
quand tu vas qu'une porte se ferme et tu
fais
les pionniers du métal orientale sont de
passage demain soir à rouzier de
touraine
c'est la cinquième édition du hem fès et
le camping est gratuit
certains
échec jeux de cartes ou de paume
françois 1er et mais se divertir il
ouvrira même la culture à ses proches en
créant une bibliothèque royale
aujourd'hui toute sa collection
personnelle se retrouve exposé au
château de blois
certaines pièces prêtées par la
bibliothèque nationale de france sont
présentées pour la première fois comme
par exemple les grandeurs d'anne de
bretagne enluminés par jean bourdillon
au total ce sont 140 pièces à voir
jusqu'au 18 octobre
non
il est là au peu de temps à vivre ici ni
bonjour
tu as aimé
va pas
et l'on referme cet agenda avec nutella
ce sera demain soir à marché noir
la semaine prochaine nous irons en indre
et loire à brémond dans l'atelier de re
l'homme dessinateur de bandes dessinées